jake paul's a [ __ ] idiot but i i
think some of it was it was definitely
like coordinated like all right let's
have it so good at selling
now they're trying to sell the angle of
him fighting both of them on the same
night right i think that that's really
what they do
i'd watch that it's interesting because
like a part of me is like
maybe they try to set it up a little bit
and then he kind of took it a little too
far that's probably exactly and that's
why mayweather
cracked him because the the biggest
difference is i think
from a lot of these youtube kids is
because they still live in their their
weird little world
well in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast
i am your host david soh oh wow we have
oh yeah we're introducing people today
man
the viewership is growing and people
people want to know who the [ __ ]
everybody is
is that is that what you do on podcast
yeah they they want to know
that's crazy this is nick the ear he
just transitioned into a boy recently
and i have a round of applause like no
applause dude good [ __ ]
i still like this now i used to sit like
this now i said like that and i love it
and i love it and then we have amber
patrick.t riley my name is my legal name
that's the license plate name and also
the license drivers names
i'm just having a stroke right now
everybody he's hanging out with me too
much bro
that's under the state of california you
know what i mean is legal
it's illegal so what's happened since
i've seen you guys last
[ __ ] you know i got new registration
tags so that's been big in my life
[ __ ] how do you do that you know um and
that's about it so it's been really good
and let me tell you what i did this
whole recently and i just probably just
found out that i'm uh
i'm my asian father to the max yeah so
everybody knows that i genuinely
genuinely changing your boyfriend
everybody going straight to my dog
i generally know about camera equipment
bro okay
also to rebuttal this david can you
rebut i haven't said anything no no no
no
when david wait researches
anything he has to know everything
you did know a lot about paint and walls
and con
what was the [ __ ] did he call it bring
the hang up he can go to home depot
and out paint any of these [ __ ]
that are talking about like oh like what
what paint do you want with this color
and like he will out swatch anybody bro
oh sometimes even the mexican people on
the corner i just sit in front of them
and they take their job
i'm stronger than them they're like but
you're korean why you talking
and they start speaking korean to me i'm
like oh [ __ ] wait what the [ __ ]
yes but this this little [ __ ] knows that
i know camera gear you know i've done a
film i've i don't know i've been on
youtube for about
i don't know 10 years and he decides to
get advice from another korean person
which i find highly offensive
yeah i don't even understand why you
would go to somebody else's korean i got
a tier koreans
that i talk so who the [ __ ] is this guy
that's right above me then this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh bark quan oh wow he's not even there
he's not even correct
quan is a korean name yeah but he's
chinese as a guest you could tell by the
square shape of his head
he do got a blockier head than yao ming
yes
bro bert that's what we call him
he's a buddy of mine that that you know
told me he's a filmmaker himself
you know and he was like hey i think you
might he gave me a good reasoning but he
also
what was his reasoning well i gave him i
was like hey i was thinking about
getting this camera and it was a 6400
sony right and everyone was like yeah
this would be good this would be good
but he goes hey
for the value of what you're going to
get with a 6400 why don't you get this
camera instead it's only 100
more and you get more options for x y
and for these reasons
right so i was like all right cool it
was like a better longer battery life
yada yada and i was like this guy knows
i'm talking about he's he's good at what
he does so i was like perfect
and then he goes get this lens try
getting this one because
i figure for what you're trying to shoot
it would make sense it would be he was
trying to give me cost-effective
things because he thinks i'm broke and
he thinks i live
in a car but i'll say how stupid this
advice is and i just good sir i
i don't know who your friend is right
and he was probably giving you advice
based on the parameters you gave him
yeah right but he also gave you advice
on stuff that he would get because
he is a filmmaker you are not a
filmmaker you are a little chinese [ __ ]
have you ever doesn't know how to do
[ __ ] right you know you need foolproof
equipment that'll allow you to shoot
i know how to use adobe premiere to the
most matte i just figured out to the
most max
to the most macs i just figured how to
use captions
okay oh and that takes way too long is
there a better way you could do captions
on them absolutely not but what are they
called they're actually not called
captions
they're called uh titles title cards
yeah titles
legacy
stupid son of a [ __ ] man that's that's
what it is i just want to know how to
use it to the max
max to the max the max you gotta you
gotta sign for my patreon for that bro
like yeah
yeah you can't do that and it's a
hundred dollars a month hit up your boy
patriots we'll see a lot because a lot
of people they give advice based on what
they would use right because he's a
filmmaker so for example he's going to
be shooting himself so if you're
shooting yourself
right yeah you probably want a lens that
does what
autofocus is right hey that i thought it
was
and he gave and he got a [ __ ] manual
lens how the [ __ ] are you going to focus
on yourself from my understanding i
thought
focus was in the camera not the lens
and also didn't know you had to buy
another lens for
a camera i got the camera and i was like
where the [ __ ] the lens at bro
i was like i'm turning it on it's white
my camera broken i don't know what's
going on
how have you survived to this point hey
man some people think
you know life is crazy bro
[Applause]
yeah yeah
dude this is my ted talk right here okay
this is the advice i give you know what
i mean
so people wanted us to talk about crazy
[ __ ] because we didn't get to talk about
this and this was passed
ufc 261 yeah right so they want to talk
about the jorge
mazdadees bro what the [ __ ]
what happened what happened dude what
didn't happen dog
what didn't happen oh he just had to
one-up us dude
what do you [ __ ] do you think you are
dude teacher we forgot to do our
homework
[ __ ] out of your dude hey a leg got
broken you know yeah
what happened [ __ ] dude the weinman
thing was
so bad that was on the same card it was
like his [ __ ] turned into gumby like
with the quickness and he tried to step
on it you see him like bro
when you were slow-mo he kicked he
didn't know it broke
are you watching this yeah yeah didn't
want to
i wanted to know when he felt it and it
was like on his way down
when it touched yeah kind of right yeah
that's when he started going oh
yeah but bro how crazy is it that he did
that to anderson silva and then that
should happen
like how wild is it there's been three
leg breaks on the ufc he's been part of
two of them that's some universe [ __ ]
right there so if you guys don't watch
the ufc
chris weidman is a middleweight
a middleweight that beat anderson silva
he's considered
one of the greatest middleweights of all
time if not one of the best
pound-for-pound
fighters in the world for sure right and
easy had not been dethroned in like 10
years it's been so [ __ ] long
and a lot of people didn't think that
chris weinman was going to be the one to
do it
now chris wyman his wins over anderson
silva has been considered very sus
right so it kind of sucks on chris
weisman reiman's side that
his victory's over anderson silva
everybody says is a fluke always always
controversy
some kind of controversy so the first
time anderson silva was [ __ ] around
hands down
taunting him he gets clipped on the chin
he falls over right
second time anderson silvan throws a leg
kick he checks it he knee checks it
snaps his [ __ ] leg and
it just disgusting there's no other
reaction
so fast forward you have a fighter chris
wyman this
fights another ufc contender i'm not a
contender before the belt but
um uriah hall yeah uriah hall
snaps chris weidman's leg the same way
that he snaps
anderson silva's leg anderson silva
being the last person
that your riot hall fought so this is
all
like weird serendipitous faces final
fantasy or not final fantasy
[ __ ] final destination one in a
million channels what the
[ __ ] it's crazy how weird is that how
weird snaps his [ __ ] leg
disgusting i think it broke skin as well
disgusting his phone was just inside his
leg like this like
just flailing that was
worse than anderson silva's initial leg
break yeah because he stepped on it
and and the way it broke it it's it was
the first strike
in the whole the whole thing it was like
let's go yeah
the bell rings they're like all right
cool they touch gloves we're gonna fight
first kick thrown murder shattered the
only fighter
in the ufc to win a fight without
throwing a strike
hey is it is that real yeah for real
who's gonna
how could you yeah how could you he won
a fight without throwing a strike you're
right hall
honestly arrived he should have finished
up and finished with punches it's kind
of
annoying that he didn't see this go
straight for a legal head kick he
literally what is it
recording no sometimes that sign makes
sense [ __ ] weird weird squeaking
noise is that on is the camera
yeah this is the red tally light on this
oh okay cool yeah
let me tell you something last time i
forgot to record and that podcast was
fire
yes it was fuego but oh well whatever
whatever dude it's in the past all right
we had a better one with you [ __ ] up
the story so yeah
you guys we made up for it yeah yeah
also in that same card uh [ __ ] the
drop foot happened which is so rare too
five before yeah and i think i really
feel michael
my [ __ ] chris wyman saw that and he
was like
lay kicks all day he throws it and then
just that's why i don't throw a little
bit
more bro i don't do that ever ever we're
not doing that anymore but what are the
odds though
think about how many ufc fights that
should happen twice yeah like that's
the odds are low yeah i just feel
horrific as [ __ ] don't get me wrong
but i just went on a watching spree of
people breaking their shins out
oh see wait you see how he does this
he's like oh now i need to watch all of
them
yeah how did that how does that happen
though so from what i've seen from all
these other videos now [ __ ] you i'm
self-conscious
all right so what i've seen what i've
researched on my off time because i
don't have anything
he's going to give you the medical
terminology too he's not going to say
bro he's going to be lying
he's going to say fracture yeah yeah so
from what i've heard
and this is this is what a lot of thai
people are saying right so in mma the
way the low kick for some reason evolved
it's with the foot up right thai people
flex down and they say they're saying
that if he flex his foot down it
actually strength
strengthens the shin bone which is how
you're properly supposed to low kick
because when you flex
the interior tib takes over i see this
guy yeah you think it's terrible
hey bro that just and when you flex down
if there's something there it relaxes it
exterior tip
yeah which is [ __ ] wait it's stronger
if you flex well when you flex
like that wait so when i kick i should
kick on my
toes pointed down to strengthen the shin
bone because when you flex up a lot of
times
the muscle protrudes more this one's
ufc fighters do right yeah ufc fighters
have been throwing their locations with
their feet
up like this that's weird yeah and so a
lot of thai people are scrutinizing that
saying well if you just did a
traditional locate like
a thai sauce people would do it you
wouldn't saw why they cracked your leg
you know that's true i heard uh bas
rutten talking about when it happened to
anderson silva and chris weidman he was
saying it was because they people don't
usually turn their hips over enough
like in in mma like a lot of guys that
you'll notice
yeah they kind of flick it and because
of that it's like hits like a weaker
part of the bone
or something like that so i don't know
if it's that or maybe that it's a
combination of things right because some
fights in the chris
in the anderson silva fight with chris
weidman he kicked initially
one time hit the knee so sometimes that
kind of like damages and creates micro
fractures too right yeah and then you do
it again
and then the perfect position like could
be the perfect combination of like being
a little too loose or whatever
yeah it's just like a perfect storm and
also thai guys like you would imagine
how hard they kick and how much they
kick it would happen more frequently in
muay thai
yeah unfortunately it really doesn't it
happens more in mma
typically speaking yeah you know what i
mean yeah well that's just how it goes
like
because i feel like their emphasis on
their kicks is
probably just just a lot better in muay
thai than this in mma just across the
board like typically speaking
so i don't know man it's the way they
condition it to
the way they the way it sounds to it
just sounds like a louisville slugger
being snapped
bro it's so gross because i actually
didn't see it initially because i was in
the kitchen
and i wasn't in the kitchen i was
walking out from the kitchen and i heard
the snack and i went
i went shin i knew it oh because i
remember the sound from
[Laughter]
but it was loud and i just kept
screaming
and screaming and screaming yeah i felt
so bad for him
but i feel like weidman should hang it
up though you know
i mean his last win that he got was
terrible
it's like it's it's like come on bro and
then that happened it's like just
you know he had a great career like
[ __ ] why why what's yeah you were
champ bro yeah you're good you did a lot
of great things you beat anderson silva
you had a great career
like he was a transition from the old
guard to the new guard
yeah you know because that's still my
ball
after his father embarrassed him like
that his career ended that should have
been the
yeah that should have been so it's
really interesting i'm done his dad's
ever since ever since then his dad has
never been alone in the octagon ever
again yeah i don't even think in the
stadium i don't even see him
at all there's only two people that have
been banned from the ufc joshua fabia
and chris weidman's dad i don't know why
he did that
yeah that that forever will puzzle me
you know what was great is how awkward
it was because like he was
like expecting like a cheer like he
yelled that and then the crowd was like
even chris weidman was like come on bro
who's the head oh ben rothwell ben
rothwell that was the other one
that was bad what the [ __ ] was that but
he's just different though he's just a
weirdo
he's a weirdo trying to do like that was
like when conor mcgregor was just around
and like every
everyone was trying to talk [ __ ] and he
was like into the he had his like wwf
persona yeah he was kane bro he was the
undertaker
why did he do that
he was like oh [ __ ] that was kind of
scary dude that was really [ __ ] weird
man he
well you know what he could tell he's
just a big nerd bro like big
harmless but he's just a big ass nerd
hey anthony smith said it the best that
[ __ ] got no it wasn't anthony
smith it was uh the redhead dragon was
his [ __ ]
paul felder paul father said that ben
rothwell has the best fighting stance he
has
southpaw orthodox and then what's it go
what do you say i don't even know all
right good job guys
i was like i don't even know i don't
remember this oh he said southpaw
orthodox and square
because this fool never never stands in
either or he always stands straight
forward he just throws his left at his
rights
constantly this podcast is brought to
you by raycon
my friends whether you are working out
you're playing or you just walking about
and you're trying to hear the best thing
you've ever heard in your life
with some amazing wireless earbuds you
need to get that raycon if you're not
using raycon
you're a terrible person i said it you
have to live with that you got to go to
sleep with the fact
that you're not having raikon earbuds
because now you've got to live your sad
sad bad life
without great music and great audio well
you could change that by getting a pair
of raycons
today listen you get crisp powerful
beats at half the price of
other premium audio brands you don't
have to pay
a premium price for premium earbuds
raycons look great and even feel better
they come in a range of cool colors and
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable
in ear fit and raycons are built to go
wherever you go
listen up raycon's offering 15 off all
their products for my listeners and
here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy recon.com brain there you'll
get 15 off your entire recon order and
it's such a good deal you'll want to
grab a pair and a spare
that's fifteen percent off at buy recon
dot com slash brain that's by recon
dot com slash brain she's like a big old
platypus
[ __ ] he's like a [ __ ]
platypus like a beard bro
and here he has his back dude he's like
side duck from pogba did you guys
put a beak on that [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna bake on there you guys say that to
that man's face he's gonna never
everyone he can be my ass so what be my
ass so what yeah
well i like man you bold today dude say
something now say you say to the camera
[ __ ] hey
ben ben rockhold [ __ ] me up bro
oh rockwell are you [ __ ] brendan shop
today what's going on bro
that clip i sent you guys is so funny yo
there's a clip shout out to brenda's
shop there's a compilation of
uh of brendan schaub pronouncing
everyone's uh fighter's
name he was like you know featherweight
champ in the world max hollywood
nice hollywood he was like defender he
goes boss bender middleweight champ
boss
he says john jones he goes you know he's
talking about bro he's talking with mike
tyson he goes you know
you know and then there's john africa
he goes who the [ __ ] is mike in john
africa bro like
and he who the [ __ ] is john affleck bro
he said john africa he said john
that's amazing is that [ __ ] racist is
that racist that's
hilarious africa that's super funny bro
i'm the
and you said john africa right john
jones name
is the same from the first name to the
last name bro
just a couple letters john africa is
good though
the funny thing is it doesn't even sound
like jon jones
at all zero percent extra syllables none
of the same letters
not a single letter's the same africa
bro yo brandon's
o-n-e-s a-f-r-i-c-a got a single letter
to the same
boy podcast and he's just mentally
fatigued bro it's just too much of
volume i'm sure
you see blood coming out of his ear he's
just like bro i can't i can't keep this
up
john africa africa bro just the
continent
the way he said cody garbrandt his mind
just gave up okay yeah that one i think
yeah
if your name starts with cody garbrandt
too long our branch cody garbrandt even
ratio
you know what i mean did you guys think
go to europe that [ __ ] mazda doll was
going to get knocked out
no that was the last thing that honestly
he's never been knocked down yeah i
called it bro i called it no you didn't
i didn't call it hey bro he's about to
fight me right now he's like i was like
he was mad you're a joy lost no i really
want i really wanted
all to win but i i had it like i was
like
uzman's a beast and i could see usman
beating mazda but i
literally never thought he would knock
him out but that's the thing about usman
bro he's getting better
he really is gonna you know and the
threat of the takedown yeah
is the it's the imminent death for a lot
of guys he always does this too right in
the beginning of the round he just
touches their leg like i can grab that
whenever the [ __ ] i want right
you just have to know it he goes down he
touches it he touches it i'm like oh
it's true he could take you down
whatever the [ __ ] he wants right and the
crazy thing about his striking is
he doesn't do anything past the jab
cross what the [ __ ] else do you need
with those long ass arms of his right
and he hit him [ __ ] hand trap cross
dunzo dude that was such a the hardest
punch i've ever in the
history of the ufc dude his whole head
looked like it spun around three times
the only other time jorge mosfetal has
been uh tko'd or like knocked out like
that
was early in his career when he fought
like japan or something oh [ __ ]
the exact same sequence happen
hook cross as he as uzman is throwing
the cross
he throws the hook gets cracked before
spins falls on his back
exact same way doug he [ __ ] got
knocked out so hard
he rested on usman's shoulder yeah dude
there was a
a [ __ ] meme that literally had me
crying laughing
because because maz vidal kind of leaned
over like this and they put him next to
a picture of a gatorade bottle that was
kind of crushed
it looked exactly the same but when he
got hit the [ __ ] water that sprayed
off his head dude
you literally saw his spirit just like
[ __ ] that
it just came out and then went right
back in he melted it looked like he
melted yeah
yeah it was bad bro usman is a
[ __ ] animal dude like he's he's
starting to get close to gsp i think
like i mean gsp i think is the greatest
welterweights
right now but usman's definitely on his
way and he's like one
fight he's like yeah a couple fights
away his next fight colby covington
if he starches he's going to i think
there's nothing else to say there's
nothing else to say there's nothing else
i mean i maybe gilbert burns one more
time
and then it's like salt i mean i think
after colby it'll be like for sure he's
there
but i think because gilbert burns gave
him a good fight i i just don't
care to see usman fight the same people
over you know i like i want to see him
fight fresh challenges but i don't know
who that's that's the thing there isn't
anybody i think yeah yeah that would be
a big fight too leon is i think he
should get the shot before colby loki
i mean the way leon edwards looked
against uh looked good
and he's big as [ __ ] y'all dude look
good he looked like he's never left
ring rust does not matter to that dude
he is so [ __ ] good
he's hella good and he has a really high
like kickboxing pedigree
i think his takedowns defense is
not going to be better than usman's
offense but i think it's gonna be good
enough for him to
have some crazy scrambles with the guy
like uh leon
with uh like like with a guy like uh
yeah yeah
so i think it's a good fight and even in
their first fight it was pretty
like it was pretty competitive yeah it
was competitive like usman won but there
were still moments where
you know leon had some success so i'm
just curious to see how that
fight plays out and leon is just big bro
he's way bigger than he was
okay who's the guy that he was fighting
i forgot his name on the law muhammad
remember the name is his nickname yo oh
really remember
remember the name yeah probably because
he can't remember his [ __ ] name
he's like i've only seen him fight maybe
once so i don't really mean
he's pretty good yeah he's pretty beasty
he took a picture next to habib
like recently habib towers over that
fool oh really thicker than that fall
oh he's small for that [ __ ] weight
class yeah he probably is he's probably
in the middle he's probably like a kevin
lee type right oh see
that sucks that's that weird weight
class where people like kevin lee suffer
yeah when they go down to 155 they're
depleted 170 they're too small
yeah that's why he's calling out mike uh
mike perry i mean that's a good tune-up
fight for him i guess
yeah mike perry i love my curry bro
like even though he loses and whatnot i
don't give a [ __ ] he's the blackest dude
in the ufc baby dude when it comes out
to halo and
like it wasn't have you seen that clip
no so so he told the guys at ufc he's
like
my walk out song to be the halo thing
the halo game theme song though
but they played halo by beyonce or some
[ __ ] yeah and bro
he's like he's the wrong song and then
he just starts singing it and loving
like dancing to it
he just like embraces the [ __ ] out of it
bro
yo they [ __ ] gave me halo by beyonce
i mean he got [ __ ] up in his last
fight pretty pretty bad dude yeah and it
was like he's never fought a day in his
life
and this dude had the calmest interview
saying that he had this full he goes i
found my new source of motivation
it's my child and then he gets beat to
an oblivion
his girl broke up with him too did she
no way he did a video about that after
the last loss
i don't know if that's the reason but um
maybe it's because she he beat up that
old guy at that restaurant
um maybe that was the reason but they
already had a kid and she just gonna
leave him like that
hey [ __ ] come on now you're trying to
get that child support money huh damn
you can't leave he loves you dude this
fool was shouting you out yeah literally
he made a video about he was like drunk
in vegas he was talking about how i was
like man my girl broke up with me bro
[ __ ] it's all good and he's afraid he
says some other [ __ ] but then at the end
he goes
hit me up if you're in vegas you're
trying to wall out
i got some [ __ ] at the end had your boy
heart broken but this dick need to get
wet yeah and
hit your boy up that's the letter well
he's on the move then i guess he don't
really give a [ __ ] yeah i mean what what
are you gonna do he seems sad but you
know what are you gonna do
just hang out with darren till because
they're [ __ ] best best darren till is
so funny bro
he's gonna fight derek brunson do you
hear that that's gonna be hilarious
they're like i just saw something about
it today that they're lying in the
clown the pictures the pictures he puts
up with derek brunson have you seen them
i have not seen
oh on his instagram it'll just like
it'll be i'll be scrolling through and
it'll be like darren till and it's a
picture of like derek brunson like
trying to look hot
like on the beach he's like biting his
lips yeah or like in the in the mirror
bro they're the corniest pictures
temperatures it's just like
no caption yeah just derek brunson
trying to like in the mirror like
showing his abs like
like this guy's a [ __ ] d-bag
how we talk [ __ ] you know the way that
robert whittaker
[ __ ] uh dismantled uh what's
what uh kevin gastelum now makes me
believe how good daryn till is because
that darren till yeah [ __ ] robert
whitaker fight was fireworks yeah yeah
it was good
busted his knee yep and he almost
knocked out whitaker out he knocked
whitaker out that's sure
yeah yeah so now's a beast he's another
guy that i really root for just because
i like him i'm like yeah
come on get it together i was bummed
when he pulled out of his last fight i
was like [ __ ]
of course that would happen broke his
[ __ ] collarbone what are you gonna do
yeah speaking of broken [ __ ] though see
that mayweather
and uh jake paul what do you think about
that i mean you know what set up or
you know what's interesting bro do a
little bit at least
dude charlotte made the god did the
funniest caption did you see that [ __ ]
he said bro i got it
oh it was the oh i think i know i think
i know what caption doug this is the
funniest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life he puts a
black and white yeah
[Laughter]
yo loki when they the first with the
video came out
and they were like floyd and jake paul
getting an argument i saw the video
initially
and i was like that ain't floyd bro and
i didn't realize
it bro i heard i heard he got hair plugs
yeah and a hair transplant like a beard
transplant too oh did he
broke his beard looks [ __ ] up look how
bit thick his hair is
and what's up with his beard i mean it
looks crazy as [ __ ] too he look
he always had a beer though no no he had
like a little he had like a little
goatee but like a full-on beard that's a
different story baby
damn i'm trying to give me a beard
[ __ ] treasure this whole said
i'm gonna tell my kids this was selma in
1965.
he cracked him did his mouth was
bleeding his [ __ ] nose was busted
damn jake paul's a [ __ ] idiot but i i
think some of it was
it was definitely like coordinated like
all right let's have it so good at
selling for now they're trying to sell
the angle of him fighting both of them
on the same night right i think that
that's really what they got
i'd watch that it's interesting because
like a part of me is like
maybe they try to set it up a little bit
and then he kind of took it a little too
far that's probably exactly and that's
why mayweather
cracked him because the the biggest
difference is i think
from a lot of these youtube kids is
because they still live in their
their weird little world well
mayweather's not from that world
mayweather's a gutter ass dude if you
looked at his biography and kind of
where he came from his father went to
prison
he had a tough [ __ ] upbringing you
can't take this dude's hat
as a joke and then he's just gonna play
it off it's like yo this young blood's
disrespecting me in my sport i'm gonna
crack this wall and he actually cracked
him in the [ __ ] mouth
yeah that was crazy yeah i was like
did him he hit him my word
my what my word but also how did you see
that i was like yeah that's what you get
dude yeah
but at the same time it's like it's all
promotion they're all trying to sell the
fight
yeah because the promo for this fight
now is even bigger
at first we didn't give a [ __ ] i kind of
still don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] either
but i'm going to watch the highlights on
youtube yeah that's exactly what more
people
that got more people interested yeah
whether we like it or not you know so
i guess but normal person yeah for sure
but i'm still not really here like it
was hot for a second but
it's still it like honestly it's kind of
but what does that mean
what does it set up a potential fight
with floyd mayweather and jake paul
yeah that's what the thing is right
because logan and jake
i mean logan and mayweather whatever but
like when you have a guy like jake paul
who's so good
at being hated and he like it's a
[ __ ] art form for this dude
like he was at the ufc at ufc 261. the
whole crowd was yelling
[ __ ] jake yeah [ __ ] jake paul
and like and he's over there recording
it filming it and the fact that you can
get a whole crowd to say that to you
and then you know what's interesting too
you know uh like the fight of the kid
malik he was actually
a mayweather sparring partner oh wow
malik's like six too
he's he's taller than me have you seen
those videos of him sparring with people
in the gym
yeah he'll go he'll go all sizes
and it'll they'll do like first one to
quit
yeah so it could be like a 20 minute
round and floyd is just
toying with these guys he don't give a
[ __ ] he don't
and he's like you could tell he's
fighting at like 10
sometimes you know and he's out there
just beating the [ __ ] out of these dudes
talking [ __ ]
and these guys who are probably
world-class fighters
just have no answer to this dude you
know because he's just that [ __ ] good
and no matter what we think about floyd
mayweather he probably is just a gym rat
yeah he just always stays in the gym for
sure and that's
why he keeps retiring and coming back
and doing all the [ __ ] because he's like
yo he probably can't get away from the
game this podcast is brought to you by
better help if you haven't focused on
your mental health this year
now's the time to start listen we've all
been cooped up tense and honestly we
know the importance of our mental health
so let's stop pushing our thoughts
emotions and feelings aside
and get the help we need because you're
that important you should be important
to yourself and you're important to me
now better help assess your needs and
get you with a
licensed professional therapist you
don't have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room
and you can message your counselor at
any time while setting up weekly
video phone sessions it's super
convenient and more importantly allows
you to be in your own
safe and comfortable environment now
i've used better help
and it was amazing and i'm telling you
right now i still use it and talk to my
counselor
i still use better health give it a try
you have nothing to lose so remember
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and geniusbrainlisters get 10 off their
first month at
betterhelp.com genius once again that's
betterhelp.com
genius like once he made all his money
you know he's just like well what the
[ __ ] else i'm gonna do make more money
and fight more people and just see what
the [ __ ] out you know you don't see
a lot of elite fighters continue to
pursue their craft
after they're done with the sport
because he's made his money
he's made his legacy and they say that
he still goes to the gym
every [ __ ] day yeah how crazy is that
dude yeah i i can't imagine doing a
sport like that where you even after
you've
you've said and you've done everything
that you have planned out to do
and you still train as if you have a
fight the next day yeah yeah how weird
is it any sharpest attack
yeah for as long as he's had a career
for and for
what is he like 44 or something like
that like 40 he's like mid-40s
and he still looks [ __ ] good dude i
mean he never really got hit
that's what i mean and it's just like
but but then again whether it's in
fights or in training
like in training is where he sustained
most of your like head trauma
across the board but the fact that he's
still like how many fights has he had 50
something at least right
just pro not including amateur or is
his olympic career but we're talking
[ __ ] such a long time at the gym and
just
and the way he he transitioned from old
school
to the new school age of boxing right so
he went through every stage of the hard
sparring
just the wars in the gym and he's still
like
sharp as a tack dude but after a certain
like i i agree but after a certain point
when he developed that style that like
super elusive style
yeah i don't know probably i'd say which
fight did that really start happening
like
ricky hatton maybe a little more yeah
wait for that for that yeah so when he
became
money mayweather at that point like he
really wasn't getting hit i don't even
think in the gym
really that much at all like it was so
hard to like you just couldn't hit him
yeah he just could not the way the rules
are set up and the way he would move and
how fast he was
yeah it was like he after that certain
point i think he only got cracked
by sugar shane mosley zab judah hit him
yeah that was it conor mcgregor yeah
baby whether it's heart shots or not
whether it's hard shots or not you're
still you're getting hit in the head a
little bit
glancing off blows you're still
sustaining something something
that billy shell defense is really hard
too
it's not one of those things where it's
it's impenetrable
yeah right you have to be really good to
be able to execute that's okay that's
why it kills me when i see people that
just start boxing
oh i do philly show it's like all right
no you don't know yeah yeah
there's literally maybe a couple of
boxers that do it well right now
yeah like devin haney now because he
trades trains with the mayweather gym
you're seeing him implement it very well
but he has a more aggressive style than
mayweather does
but he does it but you could see i mean
how many people do you know actually do
that
they do it intermittently when they have
to when they're against the ropes or
they're you know they're tired
but like exclusively doing a philly show
and like
mastering it as a floyd dude yeah yeah
he's standing in front of people and
they can't hit him back is on the ropes
and it's just like
it's annoying it's annoying yeah and
people he breaks people's wills that's
what it is it's like man [ __ ] this i
can't get this guy
exactly i feel like he's just [ __ ]
around the whole time let me ask you
something
what's up i give you a hundred thousand
dollars you find jake paul
i find 100k yeah oh this guy
oh i don't know if i'll win but i'll
fight for 100k
i'll do it but you got to win though
then you get 100k what the [ __ ] man
you're just gonna lose yeah i'll [ __ ]
get socked for 100k yeah
whoa i won't get stopped for 100k it has
to be like at least 500k
he weighs like 200 pounds how much does
he weigh he plays like 200 pounds he's a
big boy
he's like he's maybe an inch taller than
me yeah
he's jacked yeah he's a big boy huh
you do fine you got good hands good
movement good hands we'll see what
happens
i think i can survive for sure i like
that
i think if i had to wear the train train
boxing
i think you would i think you'd give him
trouble i i think he would have hard
time hitting me
double trouble baby just say it that's
it you whoop his ass
don't be a puss about it i'm gonna tell
a fight you see
i'll kiss him in the [ __ ] mouth damn
how about that wow yeah i'm coming
for your ass bro the end of bruno and
then i'll [ __ ]
put him on his back and i'll just
[ __ ] i'll molest him and there's
nothing he could do about it well how
good would it be if like that would that
like you just took him down like [ __ ] it
like if ben ashton would have just shot
a double
and dumped them [ __ ] and it would
have been game over it would have been
gay i know but like
like i just loved it it would have been
great i would have [ __ ] loved it like
when
conor f floyd like just a head kick bro
just land it
[ __ ] it dude legend forever
legend he knocked out mayweather in an
illegal rule set that was all the money
yeah
what a night guy no i mean but whatever
just legendary like yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's amazing ben askren too he showed
up to the fight looking like a butternut
squash this book looked like
[ __ ] dude was that full just
when you have when you don't have the
desire to fight and someone has all the
desire to fight
that's what happens he looked he i mean
look at this he looked like [ __ ] at 170.
yeah how what was he gonna look like at
190 yeah exactly you know
exactly he looked it was the worst he
looked like me
i'm like you look like me what the [ __ ]
are you doing he looks
worse than you yeah for sure he looked
worse than you i just couldn't believe
it that was that's
got a super muffin top yeah i was
shocked i was shocked how much he didn't
care i'm like bro
come on man that's why he's kind of a g
though like he just like yo i made my
money
i got knocked down you could tell you it
hurt him i'm sure
like in the post fighting in his eyes
it's done but at the same time it's like
that's just stung dude that's
embarrassing i like what he said he goes
no matter what happens after this fight
my life is still gonna be the same
i still got my kids i got my family i
still play frisbee golf which is way
more embarrassing than getting knocked
out by jake
this yeah yeah is that what it's called
it's called froth is that what is that
what people call it i swear to look it
up
look it up on your [ __ ] iphone one
right now
right now you [ __ ] caveman he was
still embarrassed though bro
he could say all that [ __ ] but you could
see in his eyes he was yeah yeah he's
that beat but you're an olympic
athlete and you got beat by a [ __ ]
youtuber for three years
that's the thing oh it's like that dude
he did it right jake paul did it the
right way bro he cared he wanted to win
so bad yeah and it's not like he doesn't
hit like a [ __ ] tank he hits hard
that [ __ ] hits hard
for sure it's called froth it's just
called disc golf
nah bro look up f-r-o-l-f frog
right now f what frolf ralph
have you ever heard of frolf before and
coobs also called disc golf
that's what it says also called but it's
called froth
that's that's like a urban urban
dictionary pops up first you know what i
mean well your boy from the hood what
can i say
yeah because everyone in the hood is
playing frogs
you try playing so frog one
yo after i [ __ ] do a drive by let's
play some frogs
yeah you know how it is come on now me
and i always play frog hey pick up them
chains baby
you don't get that sweet tea that's
sweet
and the place yeah that's still reserved
mickey's [ __ ] frost
it's a frog come on baby yeah that's
true though i do want to talk about
diego sanchez
this is the biggest thing that i wanted
to talk about even if you're not a
fighting fan
i'm gonna put clips into this video just
so you guys understand
how ridiculous this [ __ ] human being
is if you're a mental health
enthusiast or advocate you need to pay
attention
this podcast is brought to you by better
help no but
so diego sanchez is an og in the fight
game right
now for me i was never that big of a
diego sanchez fan stylistically wasn't
really great for me
he was just a [ __ ] maniac yeah yeah i
think he was always down on a scrap
yeah he was he was game yeah he's the
original game bread to the end of time
like this dude he also like
he had a crazy chin like nobody could
knock this full out
yeah like he was like a rabid dog yeah
like i i i don't even think
when has he ever been knocked out like
completely out i think matt brown
knocked him out
matt brown with the elbow that [ __ ] was
crazy that's right he not he's been
knocked out a couple times
like later like
and they couldn't knock him out kicked
him in the head it only stopped because
of that he
literally [ __ ] axe wounded him in the
goddamn head
his [ __ ] brain dude it was really big
he's the season one
ultimate fighter yes he is he's in one i
have seen
i had the [ __ ] dvd set yeah and
that's where that was the one that he
was in
season one and he's still fighting and
also getting his ass beat upside down by
his trainer
yeah like what the [ __ ] because that's
what he needs too much damage so what
happens is that
so diego sanchez maybe had a fight left
on his contract right
so he gets cut from the ufc
as of right now there's a lot of
controversy around him because
he decided to leave his original gym
jackson wink
and he got picked up by this guy named
joshua fabia joshua fabia is a man who
owns his own martial arts
system called the school of
self-awareness great name and he is
literally the most unself-aware person
i've ever met in my life yeah
this guy is very [ __ ] odd so you see
all these like weird
like if you notice that what's that one
instagram account mcdojo
so the if you've ever gone on mcdojo
there's a lot of people who do fake
martial arts
this guy is that guy but he somehow
got diego sanchez to come with him and
be his stuff
as well what stephen get the [ __ ] well
stefan bonner has always been really
[ __ ] weird dude yeah yeah stefan
bonner i i i'm surprised stefan bonner
isn't diego sanchez's coach
all right i didn't know he was that
weird though he's [ __ ] weird they're
connected over ufos
a quick little tangent just quick
tangent remember randy couture put out a
video of him just jerking off and
in america baby have you seen that i
thought about that the other day i was
driving i was like why the [ __ ] would he
record himself jerking off like wait
randy couture can you actually clip this
answer
dude out of nowhere i don't know what
this is like months ago
like oh maybe over a year no it was like
years ago bro
i don't know how i don't know when he
made the video i saw this [ __ ] about a
year within a year
i don't know when the video was made but
he was old he's in this like the
bathroom looks nice
good tile nice lighting nice wooden
mahogany in the back
he sets up his camera it looks like he
was in like a cabin bro but
naked just starts and like the whole
like he's like
and he recorded it and then himself
recording it i don't know who he sent it
to he sends it to somebody who also
uploaded it to pornhub or if he got
hacked
but it's literally like eight minutes of
him just and then busting
it's the most it's the oddest [ __ ] i was
like why the [ __ ] would you do that
i literally thought about that i was
driving the other day like last week and
i was like why the [ __ ] did randy
couture
videotape himself jerking off and coming
and then was like
nice and then click the video stop you
usually have posting that clarity and
you realize like i shouldn't have done
that
i'm an idiot but yeah but he just goes
that was the best take i've ever had
he's like that was the best instagram
that he gets puts on a white glove and
smokes a really long cigarette
it was great and he's a classy [ __ ] bro
randy carter
yeah sorry that was a little side note
but randy could tour two by the way
i mean i don't know who the [ __ ] dresses
this [ __ ] but he looks like he's
out to solve some crime
yeah like he hit the little handle and
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] does he always wear a scarf
when he has no neck yeah what's going on
what is that resting on
it's summer bro it's hot
you live in vegas at the beach i feel
like i've seen him wear a scarf and a
tank top and one outfit
yeah why does he always have a scarf on
he got too many hickeys bro he get just
his neck sucked on all of it no one's
talking about that video though
that he just like no one's like hey
randy what's up he's about to dm your
ass
i hope he does i'm just back waiting a
big fan but what was that about
you're gonna open up your instagram your
dms and it's gonna be a new video of him
jerking off
it's literally him jabbing up with a
scarf on isn't it
google a picture of randy couture like
18 of the photos
has a beautiful scarf and i don't he
always has a scarf what the [ __ ] is that
about that [ __ ]
the last thing i want to see a guy do is
jerk off oh 100 percent
i could curve
is there anything more like a dude just
just beating off is like [ __ ] bro like
what what was he thinking like put some
art in there you know what i mean like
making maybe he's gonna join joshua
fabian school of self-awareness
something's going on because he might
need it maybe he's the hidden like the
the [ __ ] hidden
mastermind behind it bro he might be
dude what the [ __ ] we thought joshua
fabia right
because now i'm just curious i can't get
my mind off of it
i just picked up this guy with a tangle
hat and a scarf jacking off butt naked
i'm gonna look it up ready couture got
some nice teeth bro he got some nice
veneers bro that's what i was thinking
while he was jerking off
i was like nice bathroom nice to meet
you randy couture's skin looks like he's
just
fine genuine leather at this point he's
just a calloused man
yeah no for real bro like this dude was
grunting
like he was born in 1963 that's
and he was fighting in the ufc when he
was like 43-44 still going at it
he was an expendable dog you know like
this he was like this but joshua baby is
bashing crazy
oh yeah he he's textbook narcissist in
the max so there was a clip that was
released and so
the ufc and joshua fabia have been going
back and forth because
he kind of always interjects himself
into
all of diego sanchez's stuff so when
diego sanchez is being interviewed
joshua fabia is for some [ __ ] reason
right there with him
talking for diego and not only is he
talking for diego he goes
well you guys need to put some respect
on my name
bro you're full you're 5-1 bro school of
self-awareness yes
yes [ __ ] idiot he goes in and he goes
yeah the way you guys are slandering
diego's name is actually not cool
because
you don't know who i am and starts
talking about himself yeah that's what
he does like
he'll start talking about how diego is
like being you know
[ __ ] on and he goes that's not fair
because if you knew
the stuff that i've done how i move he
goes nobody moves with me
nobody comes and works with me and
because of that
i feel like this is an unfair narrative
in the media
like he loki is like kind of donald
trump of
like the way he's calling everyone fake
news he's saying you know you're
delusional you're delusional you don't
know what you're talking about
you'll go to any commentary team anybody
that has a good name in mma journalists
world any and he questions what they
have to say
and if you were to watch this guy
whether you know anything about martial
arts or not
and you see what he's teaching how he
moves
and how he does anything you'd be like
that guy doesn't know how to kickbox or
do jiu-jitsu or any martial arts clip of
him in the ufc institution
bro the p.i chasing people with a
[ __ ] knife in the octagon
saying see this i'll stab you and he has
an actual
knife with other ufc fighters and he
goes
you know if you're not going to move
your feet in a fight
you're gonna move your feet if i have a
knife and i chase you another ring
that's his rationale and kind of fire
bro
kinda makes sense makes sense and he
will move he's chasing people around he
goes see
and they're running away from him
because he has a knife in his yeah
there's like there's a psycho with a
knife in the ring
also this is like a billion dollar
[ __ ] institution of of sports science
that they're all training in
and his methodology is chasing people
around with a flashlight
diego sanchez's story about how he got
picked up
by joshua fabia is that he asked to roll
with him or grapple with him and he did
some [ __ ] to him
that opened up his mind he goes whoa i
can't believe this five foot one guy did
this to me he tapped me out so many
times it was
i was like let's roll joshua fabia yeah
let's go anybody
anybody with a [ __ ] white belt go
roll with his ass yeah let's see
what if he just kills us he just kills
all of us see that there's a nerve right
here huh
so i just died so before he fought jake
matthews or some [ __ ]
diego sanchez there's a video of joshua
fabia
recording diego in the locker room right
before their fight he's getting wrapped
up and stuff
then the commissioners come in and
they're like hey can we talk
we do we need to talk and it's like
usually
when the commissioners come in they'll
have like a rules meeting but they
weren't talking about the rules
they came up with something that was
like hey we understand this is the her
business we understand that this is
the ufc that we're not you know this
isn't basketball like we're
we're fighting to hurt each other that's
that's the fight game right
but you can't be going around talking
about
you've been working on a new choke to
kill people like a death choke or some
[ __ ]
and he was talking about this in the
press and the media
leading up to this fight and saying that
oh yeah
me and joshua fabia are working on like
this new choke and it's gonna like
gonna kill somebody kind of like this
death choke that's he out of his [ __ ]
mind so then
like all these officials had to like
come up to him and be like hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah don't
be saying that type of [ __ ] one
and make sure anything you do is within
the unified rules of mma you know the
state of nevada
like you can't be doing this type of
[ __ ] so like this just shows the level
of [ __ ]
we're dealing with with this dude and he
keeps making headlines because
he like you know when you watch
something and you know this is just not
right
like that's what it is like joshua sure
anything you see from this guy you're
like
something is completely off he sounds
like a cult leader like
he essentially is narcissistic and he's
[ __ ] good at it yo
he's so good about that the craziest
thing too so he he joshua fabia
is the reason why diego sanchez didn't
get to fight his last fight
and the crazy thing is you know you want
to talk about disrespect but the ufc put
out
he got paid everything that was due to
him on the contract and they gave him a
bonus
bonus so he got paid like 200 g's for
not fighting
at all which is really generous that is
cool especially for all the pain that
he's put the ufc through
in the last [ __ ] year or so with this
guy joshua fabian this guy is single
henley dismantling his whole legacy
so in this whole conversation he's
talking to john anik megan o'leavy
um he's talking to angela hill
angela talking about diego sanchez
talking to him or this basically joshua
fabia josh
they do a commentary fighters meeting
before all the fights where they talk to
each fighter and they talk about their
story so they know what to talk about
while they go out to fight and they're
like oh yeah you know so-and-so is going
through a custody battle someone says
and uh he's like fun fact both fighters
that are fighting in the cage right now
are both going through custody battles
so so if you're watching this
like john he's a great commentator too
the fact that he said that i was like yo
what the [ __ ]
yeah they're like oh that's actually
pretty cool to know it's like a little
blurb at the bottom nice
so they're going back and forth and once
again [ __ ]
uh fabian is doing what fabian does he
starts bringing the conversation about
himself he goes well
and the conversation basically is he
joshua fabia asked the ufc
or they asked them to release some
medical issues that uh
diego sanchez might have had yeah the
way he phrased it
made the ufc feel like is he not fit to
fight because if he's not fit to fight
we can't put him in this cage and that's
why they released him
exactly but he goes he goes well you
guys won't he goes we can't give you
those records you have to go to the
medical side and you have to get it from
them
but he goes well he i know serious stuff
that that he's dealing with they go
hold on a second are you saying that
there's something wrong with him if
there's something we're not going to put
him in the [ __ ] cage and they
recorded this conversation
and he's so delusional he's giving the
ufc
every reason not to put diego sanchez in
that cage
and he thinks that he's winning the
conversation he drives snitching all the
time bro yeah
he's ruining anything that he does he
just ruins it by just being himself
yeah he goes there you guys aren't
giving me his his medical stuff
x-rays because i don't know after this
fight career where he's going to be at
mentally because there could be some
severe damage that i don't think oh wait
is he hurt yes like you can't he's
literally saying this and he releases
this
as his defense to how crazy the ufc is
but this is how delusional and how not
self-aware he is yeah right that
conversation
only discredited him but he thinks that
he did a great job
so it's the craziest conversation i've
ever heard in my life like you're
literally telling them
that diego sanchez is not fit to fight
that there are stuff that you guys don't
know the ufc that i know
that shows that he's medically not there
and they're like
yo if you tell me this we can't put him
in that cage yeah
like we're concerned now the week of the
fight the week of the fight
and then they canceled it and that's why
it got cancelled what a [ __ ] loser
and that's why donald trump got knocked
out is it because of him
and look what happened to donald cerrone
[ __ ] joshua fabia bro he ruins
everything dude
wow it's the weirdest thing and then now
we get to the
[ __ ] piece that rez is stones he goes
hey you guys want me to show you some
real [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] hand diego
sanchez
side down and you start [ __ ] give him
that two-piece
after he said like he has medical like i
don't know
like he's taking that [ __ ] with his
brain i don't know let me i'll help him
out
he's hitting him like this in the back
of the head in the back
he's like dude
he's like kicking him that's legit that
dude's not my fighter has been hit head
to the point where he is literally
mentally [ __ ] cut to clip of him
sucking upside the head
but but you know if you hang upside down
the blood flow actually creates
a blood brain barrier of course and it
drips it does a drip exactly
exactly bro him being upside down and
getting socked in the head is one of the
worst things you could do to him
dog yeah that video the worst
yeah it's gross bro and the whole it's
crazy they're like he's slapping him and
it sounds like this
sounds like this it goes like it sounds
like they're clapping cheeks the whole
time bro flapping cheeks
those were actually some pretty hard ass
hits dude he's punching the [ __ ] out
that's something
he's like he's whipping like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] they they think
they say you can get cte in soccer from
heading the ball
like just from hitting headers so this
is from anything bro stalking this
[ __ ] in the head
a thousand times and he also kicked him
in the head a bunch
he kicked him too i didn't see that he
kicks them in that same video while he's
hanging up he kicks him while he's
hanging upstairs
and then he has a blindfold and he has a
stick and i don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing
holy [ __ ] but he's just doing a lot of i
don't know he's out of his [ __ ]
how has he not been like knowing this
guy he's definitely done some shady [ __ ]
in the past
how have they how's this not come up
that guy's raping bro like yeah for sure
that sounds like a real
i wasn't i was surprised that he didn't
just whip out his dick and start face
[ __ ] him
oh yeah yeah you like that i'm your
coach you're chakras he's a lion
he's like they're a lion dude and then
on top of that did you hear the anthony
smith
interview oh yeah this was the saddest
thing man
he starts crying he goes anthony smith
starts crying no anthony smith
and his co-host they have a a satellite
uh
radio show what they do and diego
sanchez was one of the guests
and so diego sanchez starts going on
this long diatribe
about how the ufc has mistreated him
specifically dana white he's like
you can have a one-on-one meeting with
clay guida but not me he goes i [ __ ]
bled for this company starts crying
and you feel for him bro because he'll
for him you realize the only
loser out of all this is diego sanchez
bro
joshua fabia he's he's gonna be fine
yeah sure
he's gonna be he's probably gonna who
knows make millions and then anthony
smith you could tell he's heartbroken
dude
because he just allows him to talk he
goes this little brown boy from mexico
yeah he had nothing to say
yeah like like dana white you can't even
meet up with me have a conversation with
me
and honestly why would he because you
know who's going to be there
joshua favor [ __ ] idiot [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
yeah his new name bro yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] bag
[ __ ] you josh it is sad though because
it's like diego is obviously not the
sharpest tool in this shed and he has
taken a lot of damage so who knows where
his brain's at right now just yeah
based on the dance scrambled eggs dude
scrambled eggs he's got this [ __ ]
weirdo narcissistic creep [ __ ]
yeah that's just manipulating the [ __ ]
out of him and he found him during his
darkest time and so he prayed upon him
of course he literally did the
the religious cult [ __ ] he found
somebody he got divorced his life was in
shambles and then joshua fabia walks in
and somehow shows him the light and you
see a lot of religious cults that do
this yeah they try to do this thing
where they try to break you down
to like your [ __ ] atoms right to
where you they literally
start creating narratives in your head
you're not good enough this is the
reason why you are the way that you are
but there's something that you're
missing and that's me this
dick yeah yeah turn around
you know yeah joshua yeah joshua ladies
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag dude whatever he sucks
bro some people just need to be dude
murdered
there's one of them it's it's literally
cult [ __ ] right because
like you'll see colts will do this a lot
and so they'll do this
this once again this is like the
research that i did because i had a
friend
who joined the cult right and so and so
they didn't he didn't
he didn't know that he was in a cult
right but everybody
everybody in the outside did because he
was trying to get us
to join this cult it was herbalife huh
it's it's
honestly it's one of those type of
things because it was in guise of uh
of a business empowerment type of thing
it's not tony robbins it's just weird
[ __ ] right yeah a lot of
a lot of like businesses do that [ __ ]
like a mentorship program yeah
so this dude was basically freaking out
and kind of just cutting out all ties in
his life
right and he was doing this in the what
he was going through this life
improvement seminar well these life
improvement seminars are very odd right
because they'll talk about oh what are
your life goals what do you want to
reach
and then it's all positivity positivity
here's an example of somebody who's
great this is the person with the
12-step program
they'll talk talk talk and then they'll
do something where they'll go and
they'll start breaking you down
right and they'll start inserting things
in your head that don't exist but they
really make you believe that that it's
there it's like what do they call it gas
lighting now yeah right that's like the
hood term for me right yeah
for the screens but it's really just
manipulation
so they'll sit with you and they'll say
stuff like
so what type of a childhood trauma did
you have in your past and they go
i don't really have any look deeper
well maybe when i was younger my dad
used to hit me a lot
who else did he hit he goes um
i don't because nobody was just me he
was like really because
the way that you sound you sound a
little vulnerable right now did he put
his hands on your mother
i don't think so think deeper and
they'll start doing this
over and over and over again they'll
start creating these weird narratives
and then you're like oh i do remember
when i was a kid my mom was crying in
the room i think my dad hit her
yeah what happened then oh he probably
choked her and then they'll literally
start manipulating these stories
and they break them down like the worst
part of their lives and they start
bawling and crying and it's the stuff
that never happened
and so my friend told me that um
like we have a mutual business
empowerment yeah because what they're
trying to do
at this point is they break you down
they fix you because of the things that
they've given you now this enlightenment
now it's like okay give me the deed to
your house yeah what's your bank account
if you trust me then you have to tell me
personal stuff about yourself
send me photos of naked photos of your
of your wife
they'll do they'll do this stuff like
extortionary [ __ ] and so
this this is how cults really work
that's crazy so with this specific guy
we we knew um i knew his cousin
right and so his cousin was the one that
was alarmed the most
he starts coming through and he's like
yo i think my cousin
is joining the calls like cool because
we were thinking the same thing too
because he keeps on trying to get us to
go to this [ __ ] seminar
i'm like this is weird all it takes is a
google search and you see a list of
people talking about
what they did how much you [ __ ] them
over it's like some scientology [ __ ]
yeah so he also tells a story and he
opens up to his cousin our mutual friend
his cousin my friend that you know my
dad did all this and this stuff to to my
mom and he like abused me and then my
aunt did this and that
his on his mom and he goes oh she did it
what the [ __ ] are you talking we grew up
together
yeah like your parents never did that so
he goes yeah remember when this this and
this happened he goes
that never happened i was there we lived
in the same house
because him and his cousin lived in the
same house because they were both korean
immigrants
yeah and they were poor so they all
lived in the same house together okay
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
age was this where was this at
it was at the house at i'm making up
this part i'm not there was something
very specific it was i was at the
birthday party
um my our dad took my mom to him and
started beating her and he goes
the [ __ ] it never happened that way i
was at that point
i beat up your mom yeah
he was convinced that that happened wow
and they did that very very
his cousin told him like that didn't
happen was he didn't believe it oh wow
he didn't believe it and he continued to
be
it's crazy how dudes can just get
brainwashed like that so what happens
that's
unbelievable i haven't talked to you
since this is years ago this is [ __ ]
a long time
that's unbelievable bro yeah so these
cults do a really good job and this is
honestly what i see what joshua fabia is
doing to diego sanchez sure
he found him at the worst point of his
life and now he's manipulating him see
you you've gotten better that one fight
that they won together in the coaching
thing that was his way in
see you won that fight because of me
it's not because of all the [ __ ] that
you did at jackson wink
it's not because of any of that stuff
the reason why you lost that next fight
is because of the commentary they were
so biased they swayed the judges that's
why you lost
yeah so now he's in his head so he
creates the narrative for him
a lot of people find this [ __ ] this is
how religious cults get into people and
suddenly they ask for money
hey so uh what's the deed to your house
show me how devoted you are yeah exactly
and they go well i don't need this
material [ __ ]
yeah yeah i mean right it's crazy how
spirituality is like that that
that weird opening where because it's so
it's so nebulous
i got a thesaurus in my back pocket
it's so like vague that like if someone
has sinister intentions they can and
someone's willing to
like looking for meaning looking for
purpose like you can basically like a
virus just insert whatever kind of blood
you want
it's like a horoscope it's like the
[ __ ] it's like tarot cards bro
horoscopes come on
yeah you're right my bad
a lot of people like it's it's crazy how
many people
confidently are like yo i'm a [ __ ]
virgo like
you're all right yeah relax a little bit
too is like how they get you is they say
positive things it's always positive
character but they're pretty vague
that's what i mean it's like positive
but then let me tell you those horoscope
shifts can suck my [ __ ] dick
yeah you know people who believe in
horoscopes are people who don't believe
in personal responsibility
[Laughter]
a lot of women like horoscopes bro what
the [ __ ] yeah dude well half the girl
the people that talked about horoscopes
it's
a lot of a lot of women it's just you
know what it started off as a joke right
it started off as a big [ __ ] joke and
now people are taking it too seriously
it gets to the point where they go oh
man i just [ __ ] cursed out my mom and
i [ __ ] went bankrupt you know why
i'm a cancer no no no no it's because
you're a dumbass
that's why you're gonna do cancer things
am i right
let me tell you how [ __ ] this i
always i always did this [ __ ]
so every time somebody brought that
horoscope [ __ ] they go hey what what
sign are you
i'm like oh i'm a sagittarius they go i
see that you i'm an aries [ __ ] suck my
nuts you [ __ ] lying [ __ ] i lied i'm
born in march
yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't know what
you're talking about
though this guy is
but now they have this rising moon sign
and falling sun [ __ ] right
whose moons is those rivers and
retrograde how many rings aren't saturn
on the rings saturn on your [ __ ] how
many you have how many years old you are
you gotta cut the rings around your
[ __ ] if it's nine that means you're
from saturn
and they'll do this too i'll say well
i'm in aries right
and they go oh well what time were you
born well i could tell you're an aries
but in your rising moon
i could tell you're more like a cancer
so now you're just encompassing
everything
and you know this is the same
[ __ ] that talk to dead people
yo
yeah like oh i'm getting a t a t she's
like oh
thomas yeah she goes uh i'm saying that
somebody you cared about they're like
yeah i did care about thomas and it goes
down this [ __ ] line about [ __ ]
honestly though thomas is my middle name
that was kind of crazy
let's go i can [ __ ] see the debut
that's pretty cool dude
that's pretty [ __ ] cool i'm good dog
times you've talked to a girl though
that was
like that you thought was hot and she
was giving you that horoscope spiel and
then you kind of like what you you were
sold out a little bit and you're like
you're along with this yeah yeah yeah
i'm a libra like we're compatible yeah
it's like i love aries i am an aries
i am the god of war i started [ __ ]
assuming my greek mode and [ __ ] yeah
that's it
that's that's tight it's like listen if
you're having fun with it that's
perfectly fine but you start doing this
horoscope [ __ ] and you're a
trash bag and you're literally blaming
all of your negative traits
as if it's excusable simply because you
are
this horoscope sign is dumb my thing too
is like how
there's literally no absolutely no
evidence that this is real
and the confident like if people came
out to me like you know what man i don't
know about
like i understand like the horoscope
thing's kind of weird there's no proof
but like i feel like sometimes i do kind
of associate with these traits
i'd have way more respect for people
that like the balls to have the
confidence to be like i
am a capricorn yeah a hundred percent
like and it's because i was born on
[ __ ] three o'clock p.m
like you have to know the times now and
[ __ ] like bro how do you get off how how
do you get uh how do you get off like
with the camera on this podcast you guys
already know i already said my airy [ __ ]
i want you guys
and don't even look up these guys
[ __ ] birthdays
i want you to i want you to guess what
sign they are
you've listened to that's a good idea
multiple times and if you're wrong go
slice your [ __ ] and dick in half
all right that's worse he's already
sliced in half though but we're good
no no no no no no no quarters
i want it to be like a cross quarter
here get in the graph
xy long line this way your x and y
axis x and y axis baby let's go and also
for bonus points show me your slope you
know what i mean
whoa what's up show me your slope that
sounds like what is it what does that
mean
uh y equals m x plus b slope that sounds
dirty though
that's an absolute deal that's like some
mathematical nerd like getting freaky
[ __ ]
i just hey baby come over here show me
that slope yeah let me show you some of
this and let me see that parabola baby
let me see that i want to see them
parabolas bouncing back
on my face side by side bang bang bang
[ __ ] yo shout out to [ __ ] gilbert's
nipples bro
i've never seen nipples that size in my
life are they humongous
oh let me tell you i've never seen those
bubbles it's actually like the new times
roman bible
have you ever seen have you ever seen a
child draw an island with one palm tree
in the middle
that's [ __ ] gilbert's nipple god damn
[ __ ] these things and they're right
hands
they're long too he got something nice
areolas are huge that have shocked me
wow
quite large yeah and i know a lot of
filipino people that have large areolas
do they
men specifically it looks like the jfk
[ __ ]
like dollar half dollar i work with the
filipino dude at work i'm asking how big
his nipples are ask him do straight up
or if he wears a white t-shirt you could
probably see through it i'd be like
robert stop playing
and the gay dude once told me that a
guy's the color of a guy's nipples is
the color of his ball sack
that's true wow is that true you guys
gonna check that out and then you guys
have to confirm hey no
i already know are they the same color
as your balls have you ever checked i
was just told that i'm never [ __ ]
you've never checked you were never
curious you were never like
i think i think that's impressive
nipples bro huh i think david
i do not have people you have like brown
nipples huh i got brown and blue are
your balls brown
you for sure got pink nipples i got pink
nipples and i got pink balls
gross hey gross bro
they got a reddish hue the balls
literally look like brain
like actual braids like just like the
same thing here same thing down there
dude
yeah you know my nipples are actually
purple so you got brown balls
they're like kind of purple-ish bro
purple balls yeah they match my nipples
you got like alien balls dude
hot or cold dude that's the question
because when they cold they [ __ ]
change colors
that's true do they they do yeah when
they tighten up they get a little darker
what you do is got dark balls bro you
got dark we got black balls
yeah low-key asian dudes got got got
black balls
balls look so [ __ ] weird they look
like a sea creature dude like they
should be attached to a rock and a wave
crashing on them yeah yeah like really
yeah they really should yeah they do
these balls are weird
[ __ ] dude yeah what's up with that i
knew a girl in high school
that [ __ ] loved balls really that was
like her [ __ ] nickname you guys give her
a nickname
ballsack betty baby
baby her name was bolfina dude
you were just chillin having lunch
and everybody was talking about traits
uh like physical traits that they liked
in men right like you know what what
turns you on about a guy
now what we were thinking that she was
going to say is biceps
triceps chest literally anything
else bro and then she goes i like ball
sacks
and i'm like excuse me yeah
i've never heard anybody say a single
girl say i like the way
balls bro imagine if a dude like if if
you're hanging out with a bunch of
friends
and then one of the girls was like hey
david what do you like in women the most
and you're like
upper labias for sure oh for sure
everybody'd be like yo david murders
people here
yeah that's [ __ ] weird the clyde
horizon yeah rice
extra long this guy speaks latin bro i
thought
but the fact that you say balls yeah i
bet was that part of her identity too
she was like you know me
coming through and then she got two
basketballs
yes i am
nothing will [ __ ] a situation up more
than balls bro i remember i was i
i was playing soccer and the coach is
like giving this speech of like
how like it was just very like he was
getting inspirational and [ __ ] talking
about like your
character on the field and translates to
your character in the world blah blah
blah
and there was a guy like on one knee
like he was like kind of colin
kaepernick in it he was like he was like
this like listening like very like
intent
and we're looking at this dude and we
like my buddy alex taps and he's
laughing he's like bro look and like i
follow it down this guy's like very just
stoic looking and
out of his pants his shorts his balls
are just hanging out bro
you don't feel like drowning wait wait
wait he's like balls so long yeah
blackjack balls like those things the
mobsters used to use to hit you in the
head and kill your ass dude
well they just fill it with [ __ ]
cubes of ice yeah it's like a rock with
some quarters in it
it's like hey bro your [ __ ] beaver
tail is out dude put that [ __ ] away dude
your fault your [ __ ] chinese coin
purse get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] dude
hey some [ __ ] got long balls
bro we call those the roman penny sacks
that's that's what actually took out
david yeah yeah
he's like dude you're [ __ ] slick your
biblical slinging rocks are out
and it was just it was just balls bro it
wasn't even like a rock we just give him
all these [ __ ] analogies he doesn't
know what we're talking about
david and goliath are out bro he's the
chinese coin purse what
your roman coin purse he's like what are
you talking about he's still standing
there he's [ __ ]
shackles the grass you're sheckles dude
dude your rupees are out dude how does
that happen bro i don't know how do you
not notice yeah you don't notice you're
falling
you don't feel the wind and also back in
the day in high school the gym shorts
they give you
pretty long very long but also mesh
you can feel it it was a mesh everything
you know what i mean it was a mess and
it doesn't keep your balls together like
what kind of [ __ ] underwear you're
wearing bro
yeah that dude was i don't think he was
working
underwear dude if you've got long balls
you can't wear boxer briefs and [ __ ]
like yeah also
we're boxing like you you're just not
you're a fool you're blue
you're a fool right yeah seriously
you're up a phone
you're you're awesome
when i think about weight training and
football so when i was in high school
uh i couldn't do a push-up till i was a
[ __ ] sophomore
damn because i just i was such a fat
little [ __ ] right
there's some other stories too but we'll
go into it but that's long but i joined
uh so i joined a weight training class
my sophomore year in high school
i couldn't i remember the weight that
they put on it was
a 25 plate and a 25 plate couldn't bench
that [ __ ]
it was so [ __ ] hard and i'm i was
this size
at in high school at the time it was
[ __ ] embarrassing so
me being me had a chip on my shoulder
i'm like i'm going to
do this really well yeah well because of
that weight training class there were so
many
[ __ ] weird misfits that would join
weight training because that's the only
thing that would do who would [ __ ]
join weight training a bunch of thugs
and [ __ ] miscreants yeah people who
have chips on their
so they're like a swole bro there was
this one dude in my weight training
class that i was so scared of and this
dude
used to just rack up weights and just
bounce the weights off his
barreled chest he was a samoan [ __ ] of
course
legit i [ __ ] you not this will look like
[ __ ] maui like
long curly flowing [ __ ] hair you're
welcome
[ __ ] always wore the blue rag out of
his [ __ ] pocket blue from head to toe
it must be exhausting having a dress in
blue all the time bro you know
this dude i don't know if i told anybody
that's even from my high school but
that dude used to always [ __ ] scared
we used to like crack jokes about him
behind his back
sure ain't trying to get our ass be shot
but i was walking home one day
from high school and this dude actually
transferred from our school from another
school because i think he got expelled
for
doing some stupid [ __ ] some [ __ ] [ __ ] i
[ __ ] you [ __ ] not this is what this
guy did i
so after school ended i used to walk to
the back of the school and there was
this cutout
of the fence that would be a shortcut to
go to my house it would it would cut the
walk time by like five minutes
so i see this dude this samoan dude and
i'm looking at this dude from the
distance
there's this kid riding his bike and i
see the simone who just kind of just
walk up to the kid
he [ __ ] sucks this kid upside
knocks him out and he gets on his bike
it starts riding away
just did i see this kid just oh
he's knocked out and i that's the noise
people make
when they get knocked out like
out of nowhere just walks up to the kid
and sucks him on his dome
knocks this kid out and you know what
the funniest thing is this dude's like
250 pounds and he was whining away in
this little bmx
why did he taste that why he knew that i
saw him
uh steal that bike oh [ __ ] what's up d
so let me tell you something dude never
talk to me
at all and i kept my distance from this
dude right sure
[ __ ] you [ __ ] not i'm on the bench
sitting down this guy puts his hand
on my shoulder the next day he goes
what's up so he's like you was at the
tennis courts yesterday i was like
nah he goes yeah you went there i was
like
no i was not this will threaten me dude
wow like that with his meaty [ __ ]
maui
dwayne johnson hands dude and i felt the
weight of the world on my shoulder god
damn bro that was scary strong
[ __ ] are scary bro
look he's [ __ ] 15 he shouldn't be
benching like 250
like nothing just bouncing that [ __ ] off
of his [ __ ] scary bro
yeah man and he's a [ __ ] you don't give
a [ __ ] he sucked this little
eight-year-old up into my
body socket eight-year-old he had to do
that he could have came up to him and
like
i want the bike yeah and he would have
given me off of it but he
knocked out this little kid it could
have been a little kid or a full-grown
asian man i don't know but either way i
couldn't tell
it was at a distance either oh my god
[ __ ] dude
that's so scary yep big strong
[ __ ] like that
he didn't stay at the school for long he
he oh yeah yeah
oh he didn't yes i am
freeze frame i i don't remember his name
but we had so many funny moments in that
[ __ ] weight training class
there was the other dude man we name it
we should call him kill a cow
this is the killer cow yeah yeah cow
kill a cow
right this dude he ended up going the
military like straightened out or
whatever
but this guy roasted this kid named
billy right
billy was another fat asian dude i was
also a fat asian dude but billy was kind
of like a
he was a little odd very nice dude but
he was known for
he would never put his books into the
locker room but he would always carry it
on his back
this dude fat as [ __ ] i [ __ ] you not but
if you put that fool in a quarter mile
sprint he's dust in your ass
really right and he's fat and so when he
would have these backpacks on his back
it would be so heavy
it would lead off to the right so when
this fool would run he would run like
this
sideways run into a circle you would see
this [ __ ]
dust people dude wow but this dude i
remember billy got so embarrassed
because killer cow just had to make fun
of this fool because billy is doing the
sit-up test
and you know it's always funny when
fatter people do sit-ups right yeah
range of motion
there exactly so he's really fat and you
see this just
try to do sit-ups i'm not laughing
because i'm fat too because i know i'm
coming up next yeah
you best believe he's hating his life
right now because you best believe i'm
not going to [ __ ] out this dude
because i'm coming up next sure
so this dude is doing these sit-ups and
he's reaching out
right i'm not laughing i'm mortified
because i'm coming up next damn but kill
the cow
all you gotta do is beat him though yeah
that's the thing so kill the couch
comes out of nowhere right and this fool
says looks at him he goes and this is
not even that funny but the way he said
it
had the whole room died he goes this
[ __ ] looked like he praying to
allah and everybody dies laughing
and this will billy get so embarrassed i
felt so bad
and then thank god he did that because i
didn't do my sit-up test after that
nuts dude high school was rough dude bro
kids are brutal
i don't give a [ __ ] dude the things that
we used to say to each other
like so in high school man like across
all right like because we
our high school was pretty diverse but
like we just had smaller populations
very small asian community very large
black community
very large brown community and like a
bunch of armenian dudes and [ __ ] so we
were pretty mixed
but we would say like the most racist
[ __ ] to each other all the time people
used to call us like chinca's phone you
know like whatever like it was like a
thing
like we but we would say crazy [ __ ] to
each other all the time yeah
but the things that we could get away
with saying back then
[ __ ] dude we beat this oh absolutely
yeah but i feel like it's still like
that until this day
everybody just pretend like they're
holier than that yeah online
they're gonna say how dare you say this
stuff but in your small circles you're
saying all this dumb stupid racist of
course right of course
because that's what homies do yeah like
yeah the black comey was going to say
some asian jokes the asian homies and
black jokes the mexican dude
it was all fun and games right but
there's a problem when they do that and
they go online and they act like they're
better than everybody else like yeah
you say that within your inner circles i
would never
[ __ ] that you shut the [ __ ] up shut
your lame ass up dude then i don't want
to i don't want to hang out with a
[ __ ]
joker bro yeah you better call me a [ __ ]
when i see you yeah yeah
yeah yeah which i don't even know the
origin of the word spit
i don't think it's either it's just i
don't understand what i don't know it's
offensive i just don't know what it
stands for i don't i don't know if it's
for
hispanic isn't it yeah or i don't know
if it's puerto ricans or just hispanics
in general
you know that's true so we're gonna talk
about [ __ ] hold on let's find out
what's his name
canelo no not well tony hinchcliffe
what you're gonna talk about that no on
the next podcast
yeah so well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
uh you could catch nick at nick the air
buying improper equipment without asking
the right person going to the wrong
shop if you guys want to see my camera
buying guide you know going nick
you are going to return both those
things yeah i'm gonna turn it bro if i
just gotta go and get my ass before i
return that [ __ ]
and you are not gonna buy a new camera
yeah yeah i got it i'll figure it out
all right and you could catch up to
wireless there it is
there it is
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] with a straight face too he
goes to john africa and he said like
everyone else
talking about oh yeah john bunce i'm the
one with cte
what the [ __ ] patrick.t.riley on
instagram
and you can see whatever he's doing at
stand up and catch that [ __ ] on
instagram give them a follow we'll see
you all next time
john africa